This library is full of historic treasures.
The Trinity Library in Dublin, Ireland, was founded in 1592.
Its most famous area is the Long Room.
This 213-foot room houses 200,000 of the library's oldest books.
The room is lined with marble busts, many of great philosophers, writers,...
...and people who supported the college.
The Long Room is also home to one of the last remaining copies...
...of the 1916 Proclamation of the Irish Republic;...
...the Trinity College harp, which is from the 15th century, and the Book of Kells,...
...an illuminated manuscript of the four gospels that is from the 8th century.
It is the largest library in Ireland...
...and as a copyright library,...
...it can obtain books and materials published in Ireland for free.
It is the only library in the country to hold this right.